- [Mark] Toya, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Toya] Um, Los Angeles, California.
- [Mark] And you grew
up with both parents?
- [Toya] I grew up with,
on 108th and Central,
with not my dad, just my
mother and my grandmother.
- [Mark] Okay.
And how was your childhood, generally?
- I had an abusive childhood.
I was abused by my brother a lot.
He beat me up til he beat
me unconscious one time.
I was in the hospital
for two days for that.
Um, he was very, like, irate
without through his life,
he had a lot of, growing up,
bad things that happened to him,
so it reflected on us,
and he took his anger and abuse out on us.
- [Mark] What about, did your mom step in
and protect you, or?
- My mom really didn't
step in and protect me.
I was raised in a Christian home,
so it was more so that
whatever happened to you,
just let God forgive them for it
and God will take care of the problem.
It was more so that, it
never really wasn't no,
you know, let's get the police involved
or anything like that,
but my brother beat me for years.
- [Mark] Wow. That's terrible.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then, eventually
you guys got older.
- When we got older, the last time,
I'm 39, so the last time he
put his hands on me I was 24.
- [Mark] Oh, so it continued?
- Yeah, it continued for a while.
Um, I had a baby brother
that was abusive also,
and one time I was driving,
I was at church, this happened at church,
and um, they got upset because
they wanted to use my car
to go to Marina Valley,
and I wouldn't allow them to use my car,
so my baby brother jumped on me
and, um, he tried to beat me up,
and it happened at church,
and I ended up taking my
car and I tried to run away,
but the car ended up
spinning out of control
and it almost hit my
brother, and he almost died.
- [Mark] Where do you think
their anger came from?
- I think a lot of their
anger and frustration
came from my father.
My father was abusive towards my mother,
he beat her for 11 years,
til one time that she was
blind for like four days.
So, I think it came from
my father, so to speak.
- [Mark] Yeah, that would make sense.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Wow.
So your dad was in your lives for a while?
- He was, he was in and
out of my life for a while.
The last time I had talked
and spoken with my father
when he found out what happened,
it was after me getting
raped by my cousin.
I got raped by my first cousin, um,
by the name of Dejan Taylor.
He raped me when I was 15 years old.
He molested me for like four years,
then he raped me after that,
so he was molesting me when I was a child.
- [Mark] Oh, so even
before that, he was...
- Yeah, he was molesting
me when I was a child,
and my parents, my mother
believed the story,
but my auntie didn't believe the story,
which was his mother.
Um, she passed away by him.
He drowned his mother.
- [Mark] Did he get caught?
- No, he didn't get caught.
They just didn't see it as a drowning.
They seen it he was trying to help her.
So, he's been running for some years,
but they didn't see it as that.
- [Mark] Oh.
So do you talk with your family still?
- [Toya] I don't really
speak with my family.
Um, every now and then,
I have a sister I go to church with,
I speak with her from time to time,
but I don't really talk
to my family like that.
We don't really have a
connection like that.
- [Mark] And so eventually
you left home on your own?
- [Toya] I went out on
my own at the age of 18
and then I went to CCC,
California Conservation Corps,
and then I ran into this lady
by the name of Andrea Johnson,
she ended up becoming my godmother,
and then I was on my own
with her for a while,
and then I ventured off
because I ended up being a lesbian
and I was in a relationship
with this girl,
so my family was always against
my homosexual lifestyle,
and that's where a lot
of abuse came from, too,
because they didn't want me to be gay,
they felt that putting their hands on me,
or, you know, speaking
to me some type of way,
that it was gonna change the
fact of who I was and who I am,
which that doesn't have
that, that's not gonna work,
so they judged me a lot,
so I was on my own for a while,
and then I end up moving in
with my first girlfriend,
and we was together for like five years.
It was a cool relationship,
but it was a lot of abuse, too,
and neglect in that relationship,
because I found myself doing,
repeating that same cycle,
putting my hands on her,
I was fighting her a lot,
so, but it came from a lot of hurt
and pain and abuse from my childhood,
and then at the age of 26,
27, I end up going to jail,
then I end up going to prison,
and I did my time in prison,
I was in prison for a couple of years,
and then I got out on parole,
and after I paroled I
came down here to Skid Row
and I stayed at the Weingart,
and then I was at the Weingart
for like a couple of months
before I became on Skid Row,
and then I was, like, in and out,
so I just got outta
prison not too long ago.
I did another prison term,
I just got out of prison not too long ago,
on May 4th I was released, of this year,
so I've been, like,
living here and there and here and there.
- [Mark] What were you in
prison for, the two times?
- I was, my first term
was a terrorist threat.
It was assault on a police officer.
I ended up putting my hands on a cop,
I fought the police and then
my second term was grand theft.
- [Mark] And, so you're
living on the street now?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And are you
using any of the drugs
that are out here?
- I use crystal.
- [Mark] Crystal, how long
have you been using that for?
- I've been on crystal for like two years.
- [Mark] And were you using
any drugs before that?
- No I wasn't.
And then it was pills,
I was using, taking pharmaceutical
drugs, which is pills.
I was on pills for, like, nine years.
Taking narcos and somas
to take away my pain
or just numb me to the
fact of what's going on
in my life, you know?
Not having a father being there for me,
and me and my mother not
having a real close connection,
you know, I was doing that for a while.
I overdosed one time in my house.
My neighbor came and
she found me and I was,
or I had overdosed from the
pills that I was taking,
so that kinda lured me to try
and stop me from taking them,
but I haven't really stopped taking them,
I take them every now and then.
- [Mark] And what do you do for money now?
- Well, I'm not working
at this current moment.
I'm with a temp agency,
so I'm trying to get work through them,
but I'm not really employed right now, so.
- [Mark] I mean, there's a lot of ways
for unemployed people to make
money out here on the street.
- It's a lot of selling drugs.
What I used to do when I wasn't working,
I've robbed people before.
That was my making my wheels
and making my meals and making money.
There was one time I even robbed
this neighborhood weed store.
I robbed them.
I've did a lot, I did, uh,
fake checks, fake
identity, false identity,
identity theft, I did that too.
- [Mark] Just trying to survive.
- [Toya] Trying to make it.
It's hard out here.
- [Mark] Yeah, I've heard it all.
All right, Toya, thank you
so much for talking to me.
- [Toya] You're welcome.
- [Mark] And sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck with everything.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- All right, you're welcome.